感觉全部都是你看到那种国外明星级别的。
我现在这个情侣里面你知道吗？
我发现不要去住什么中国人点了。
真的就是这些情侣里面。
而且很舒服
躺着外国人静音的特别好。
真的夸张
甚至在厕所排队的时候。
也是想唱就唱要唱的响亮。
但如果在旅游上
我会想到
我会在旅游上
未来准艺术家
前一阵子我不是去了菲律宾学英语吗？
其实我在学习的过程当中。
就去之前我就碰到了另一个有名朋友。
Lokasi
他也在菲律宾学习了一个月的英语。
这一次呢？
我想邀请他
我们一起来聊一聊菲律宾学习语言的建文。
还有优势劣势
请Lokasi来做介绍一下吧？
Hello 大家好。
我叫肉肉
我也叫Rokasi也可以。
然后我是2023年底从互联网行业Lokasi。
现在是一名正在旅居中的自由设计师和旅行领队。
听起来很洋气
非常适合有名的职业。
首先我来说一下
我们俩为什么会选择去菲律宾游学。
因为其实我当时还特地写了篇文章。
说我去菲律宾学英语了。
就很多人也表示非常的费劫。
我不是想着说我要去周游世界吗？
去年
我说我要去周游世界的时候。
然后其实很多人也表示了一个很羡慕。
可是我正在在周游世界的过程当中。
我就会发现我的英语真的菜的不得了。
然后很多时候就是很难去交流。
在这个一年多的挫折当中。
我觉得英语真的是不得不学了。
反正回国的时候
中间6月份回国也待了4个月。
想着没事干就去学英语吧？
我基本上把什么青脉的语言学校。
尼泊尔学英语
艾尔兰学英语
什么英国 欧美
各个国家都扒了一遍。
然后菲律宾
我分析出菲律宾其实相比而言。
听着应该是最能帮助提升的。
因为它是从早上上到晚上的。
那种斯巴达式的教育。
就是全天后课程
然后也有很多的一对一课程。
因为像我们如果在国内找那种一对一。
还是挺贵的
所以我后面做了一个理性的分析之后。
我就选了菲律宾
哪个是你呢？
跟你刚好相反
我完全没有做任何的分析。
就是无脑冲
因为我一开始的动音。
就是被我的一个好朋友。
然后他叫管管
我跟他做了网友也挺多年的。
也是最后在渔村的树子游民公社。
就忠于面积
然后成为了非常好的朋友。
然后他当时在疫情的时候。
在我现在的学校
度过了三个月的一个学习的时光。
然后他把那三个月描述成一种。
像乌托邦和天堂岛的感觉。
因为他是我认识的。
我觉得我身边最有生命力。
然后最有精力
最到处跑最有能量的一个女生。
然后尽管如此
他依旧把那段时光。
当中是他人生非常非常特别。
和难以取代的高光时刻。
所以我就是狠狠地吃下了这个爱丽。
我就没有任何研究说。
不同国家学英语怎么样。
或者甚至不同学校怎么样。
我就找了他的同款中介。
我就说我就要报这个。
你给我看什么时候有位置。
我要去
然后就定下来了
原来是这样
因为我很大程度上。
我一直是一个非常批的人。
就是我完全就是顺着心意。
乱走 乱做一些决定的。
但是学英语这件事上。
为什么我如此地
想了又想 计划了又计划。
就因为踩了太多坑了。
就是我找了很多的。
就想提升英语的方式。
老实发现都不行
但其实菲律宾我在出国前。
我就已经知道菲律宾学英语了。
可是我一直是没有去的。
因为我没有像你接受到管管这样的。
就是那种乌托邦式的安理。
我对学英语或者国外的世界。
就是还是有很多的害怕的。
因为英语太差了
就是那种高考59分。
没有办法交流的那种。
这样的话你就
就像你不会游泳的人。
你对水就会有一个天然的恐惧。
的确是
那感觉就是我们俩。
就原动机器还挺不一样的。
你其实就是完全冲着说。
要提升英语能力
但我其实的主要的目的是。
为了玩和体验
比如说我想去拥有一种。
出国游学的体验
因为我可能以前上学的时候。
没有出国国
但我一直自己还是挺想要。
拥有这样的经历
所以我觉得可能这样一个月的。
这样子的经历
也算是一种最小单位成本。
去弥补我当初遗憾的一个选择。
然后很期待会可
比如说来自不同国家。
不同文化背景的同学。
一起高强度的学习生活社交。
却碰撞出的化学反应。
包括说我还是想要去。
在菲律宾完成疫情前。
就像考学院有证的这项冤枉清单。
所以我当时就是来着说。
主要是为了玩和体验和旅游。
如果能学到英语
那会更好
所以这可能也是为什么？
我没有做太多的一个。
在英语学习这块的研究。
就直接订了票
我觉得每个人人生路径真的不一样。
我当时辞职的时候。
其实有菲律宾这个选项。
但是那个时候我完全不想进去。
因为我觉得这种全天候斯巴达。
太痛苦了
因为我本身就在校园里。
做老师之前
我觉得我不想再进校园了。
我都自由了
我还要去学校里面。
我当时第一个反应就是抵触。
你知道吗？
虽然我很想提升我的英语。
然后后来过了一年多。
我其实不断有找过各种。
真的是各种
就是那种很接地气的方式。
去提升我的英语
其实也有进步
但是很缓慢
然后我是真的忍无可忍。
在碰见一些老师
我觉得进步很缓慢的时候。
我觉得OK
那我就去找一个非常严苛。
一个要求的学校
我要斯巴达的斯巴达。
然后选了一个特别严的学校。
是四五第一个语言学校。
然后也是那种管得非常严。
测试很老旧的那种学校。
我真的在这个学校。
这个环境其实还蛮让我一某的。
虽然我觉得英语是有提升的。
就跟你真的不一样。
因为像你刚说的斯巴达和半斯巴达。
我觉得可能不了解的朋友。
大家也可以解释一下。
因为我也是在跟我的中间聊的时候。
我才知道原来有这两个词语。
去形容不同的学校制度。
然后我想都没想到就选了半斯巴达。
因为我就斯巴达
我听着我记得很痛苦。
从早到晚上课
就是早上8点钟开始上课。
上晚上还有三节自习课。
且你不能在这个自习课前外出。
就是说你今天万一没课了就周五。
你也要上到8点半以后外出。
那种更硬的斯巴达上了。
晚上10点的
你就是不能出去
对你就会被关在那里。
然后就是你要出去的话。
除非你生病 你要打架条。
然后比较严格
就是你要是
它会有一个规定的时间。
你晚回来一分钟
你就会被扣分
扣分扣到多少分
你可能会被退学
还不还给你学费
就是非常严苛
甚至就是它的条款。
非常的不敬人情
就是没有任何的弹性的那种感觉。
是的 我们这边也是。
就入学的第一天
就是给你过秘密麻麻的学校的制度。
告诉你扣多少分
要被退学要怎么样。
怎么样会被罚款
这种学校来之后
斯巴达对我而言
确实没有那么合适。
对自己高估了
就说到这儿我们就刚好。
可以讲一下这个学校的感受。
因为我为什么一定要去讲这个呢？
首先啊？
因为我先吐槽一下这个校园环境。
就我们刚刚收到
我是一个非常老旧的学校。
然后那个学校叫CPLS。
它是年代比较久远的一个语言学校。
我真的去之前
因为我之前说的这个背景。
一年多的就是受到英语上的打击。
我是姓氏淡淡的要提高英语啊？
我就觉得我一定会去好好学习的。
然后去了以后
我看见这样的宿舍环境。
就是跟我比我大学的宿舍还要比较。
就是它的颜色很深。
它整个环境就是房间是不明亮的。
然后感觉这个墙都是那种老旧的脏脏。
但其实它不是脏
它也还是它的干净的。
只是会让你很抑郁。
就是晚上那个空调声就很响。
就感觉一直在这种高科技的噪音里。
很痛苦
你睡不好
对 我有看过你们那个宿舍的照片。
就有点像现成里面的那种。
宝剑美容院的感觉。
就毫无神魅
就床单乱搭
然后颜色也乱搭 对。
如果看的是我的房间。
我发出来那个小粉红。
那可能还是当时最好的房间。
其他的不像美容院。
像陈中村要拆建的那种。
你懂吗？
而且你们学校的价格也没有差很多。
因为这需要注重失资嘛？
我价格其实差不太多。
说你是一个月大概1万3。
我这边好像也就贵个1000多不到2000。
你那个是亚斯嘛？
我和米亚斯也差不多这个价了。
因为我不是去了你们学校有一次。
我们两个不是要去潜水啊？
干嘛的
我找了他们学校一个朋友去搭车。
然后我才真正的去到了你们那个学校。
我发现他在那个CIA嘛？
就肉肉在CIA嘛？
他是就是最新建的一个校区。
我发现这个差距太大了。
就那学校豪华的
我觉得我是就是来享受这种财乏待遇的。
您当时有进去吗？
没有吧？
只要门口看了一眼。
门口看了一眼
他也不会给我进去。
但你门口的咖啡厅也很。
就是很高级的感觉给我一种。
对 门口咖啡厅
它是一个很综合的一个远区。
又有咖啡又有Spot又有住宿。
据说也是同一个韩国老板开的。
就包括学校对面有交囊酒店。
就把你学生
就是出了校园后的所有的生活。
也是要很赚你一笔。
就真的有商业头脑。
那很好啊？
我觉得他赚你钱
但是他把服务做到位就行。
对 因为我当时看了管管给我展示的。
就CIA学校的校区的照片。
卯一整个大震惊
就怎么可以长得跟五星级度假酒店一样。
然后实际上就到学校入住以后。
发现他的卖家秀和买家秀。
基本没有什么差别。
就不论是从他一个酒店式的装修风格。
然后到学校内整个配套的功能区域。
我就只能说他不愧是。
速务学校里硬件排名第一的。
他整个学校虽然占地面积不是特别大。
但是五丈俱全
听说我们学校的健身房是整个速务。
就不论是商业健身房还是学校。
都是最顶尖的
就甚至比我在国内。
去过的很多器材还要齐全。
还是那种落地窗和海景的。
到时候我就可以贴张照片在收脑子里。
除了健身房我们学校还有个。
无比巨大的游泳池。
还有KTV
还有台球桌
甚至给你搞了一个那种拍大头贴的机器。
就如果你周末被禁足。
只能待在学校
也完全不会觉得无聊和没有事情做。
出到这里我就是真的很痛苦的。
要吐槽一下我们学校的那个健身房。
我是觉得我是要来这边本来想调节身体。
好好吃饭
好好学习
好好运动
但那个健身房真的是让你踏足一次。
就不想踏足第二次。
你站上那个跑步机。
这个跑步机有时候。
就感觉你要人去把那个链条给踩动。
而且踩着踩着你要是跑太快了。
你还会被卡住
就感觉你会摔倒在上面的那种感觉。
是那种老式的那种机械式的跑步机吗？
不是
就是那种正常的跑步机。
但它应该是很多年了。
因为它是第一家语言学校。
我觉得应该很久都没有更新过。
东西和设备了
然后它就一直都没有更新。
所以导致你跑的时候。
你觉得这个机器已经没有润滑液了。
你可以体会我的感受吗？
我也略能
就是让你一个好好学习。
不要想得有的没的。
哦 但就很多人会觉得。
那在这里这边会很好好好学习。
我原来也是觉得我这样可以的。
但其实我是真的不可以太了解自己。
不然我也不会去看世界对吧？
我就是受不了原来的那种体制内的。
这种压迫式的教育。
我现在得出来一个结论。
我要对自己更了解一点。
不要把自己当学霸。
我觉得你是有这个学习的心的。
但是因为比如说你一下子。
从一个相对比较自由的状态。
进入到这种很严苛的制度里边。
我自己也适应了其实蛮久的时间。
就前一两周说真的很痛苦。
有点轻微坐牢的感觉。
然后因为学习强度太大。
整个人就还蛮身心俱皮的。
虽然就六点就下课了。
但我完全
我甚至是在最后一周。
我才有这个心力去踏足。
我们学校的健身房。
因为可能前三周的时候。
就是真的太累了
穿起来会有一种逆反心理。
就突然
因为我们都是比较自由。
不然也不会出来做游民嘛？
比较自由的性格
就你的个人学校我不知道。
你起码还有那么多的空间。
我就两栋房
然后你又不能去外面。
然后感觉天台才都是黑的。
呼吸的空气都是污染的。
然后整个人就觉得。
我为什么要在这里好抑郁好郁闷。
但其实当时是可以换的。
只不过会亏点钱
如果我来过你的那个CIA。
我可能就会选择换掉了。
我没来过吗？
我就觉得可能也差不了太多。
我就懒得换
我来的时候已经这个时间。
已经没多少了
换也比较麻烦嘛？
就不换了
我真的是觉得
天啊 我当时跟你去牵手。
我就应该去你们学校看一看。
那差太多了
我觉得说不定我们就能做同学。
对 这么觉得
毕竟你这个压似程度。
这个基础太好了
你起码是6.5的基础。
跟我这种一两分的有点差距。
但平时可以一起玩。
因为我会发现
一个让你心理上会更加舒服一点。
就是你在这边会有一个。
自己的一个小的社交圈。
会有一种情绪支持。
也会对你去度过
这种难熬的学习时光。
也挺有帮助的
大家会交一些国外的朋友。
但我发现真的到最后。
就是你像有一些深度对谈的。
那种朋友
深度的关系
还是要就是很难气和到国外的。
就是因为你国内的。
不一定能碰得到
就是你需要比较顺畅的。
进入一种深度交流。
这个还是蛮重要的。
所以很多人还是会跟。
自己相同语言的人做朋友。
我有时候也这样
因为懒得社交了
每天聊来聊去
就那几句话
Where are you from。
大概就是
对 你会待在这里多久。
你来这么怎么样
你从哪里来
为什么来这里学习。
灵魂三连问
对 基本上
然后你突然尴尬了。
聊完以后就聊不下去了。
如果他帅的话
你称赞一下他
如果他美的话
你称赞一下他美了。
如果聊得好的话
我在加硬丝 你知道为什么吗？
因为我发现
加了硬丝的那些人物。
因为硬丝不能改备住。
导致我都不知道谁是谁。
对 我也是
如果在硬丝聊天
我真的搞不清楚谁是谁。
所以我后面就不加了。
我觉得好累
就加完以后
让我的硬丝库
更搞不清楚谁是谁。
conficient。
我其实加了硬丝
更想的是
就是能丰富我的硬丝的列表。
比如看看
世界上不同的人
他们在用什么样的生活方式。
说我懒得加了
但我也加了不少
就我毕竟是个一人嘛？
不过说到这里
因为两个学校之间。
这样的差距就是
我之前碰到了
你们CIA的同学。
他跟我吐槽说你们老师。
比较水
然后有一些口音很重。
这个你怎么看
这个的话实话说
我朋友在我报名之前。
就跟我讲过了
就是说
CIA这边的话
不是以师资文明的。
它更多的是以
比如它的硬件设施。
以及它经常会举办一些。
非常丰富的校园活动。
然后来文明的
而且我们学校是一直在扩张嘛？
因为它可能
Marketing营销这块做得比较好。
比如说像另一个学校EV。
所有的学生加起来。
可能就100多个。
但我们学校
学生的总数可以到5-600。
那老师对应的数量。
也差不多是同等的量级。
因为有很多一对一的课程。
所以可想而知
当老师的数量一多。
你一扩招
你这个门槛其实是很难保证的。
然后整体的质量也会被稀释。
但是我自己是换了三波老师。
基本都没有遇到很重的口音。
大部分都是蛮纯的美音。
稍微有时候会有一些。
菲律宾的那种音调出来。
但是我觉得就瞎不掩瘀。
所以我觉得这个也是要看自己的运气吧？
因为一开始
你到学校
你入学测试之后
学校是会随机给你安排一个课表的。
那一开始随机的那组老师。
我自己感受下来的确很水。
质量不行
我会就是想说可以学到更多的。
比如说亚斯音识技巧。
但是可能那一波老师就是带你做题。
然后批改
然后就没了
就还不如我去跟Chart GPT互动。
我觉得可能都能学到更多。
但就比较好的
就是我们学校是有制度。
因为其实你们学校应该也有。
就一周可以申请换一次课表。
你可以指定您想要什么量的老师。
我后面就主动收集了一份。
就在学校里面最顶尖的。
亚斯老师的团队名单。
然后去主动的排兵布证。
然后换完课之后
上课的综合体验就有指数级的增长。
就觉得换了以后一天学到的内容。
感觉比我一开始
一周学的还要多
那你这个先拿到名单会好很多。
因为我刚开始来的时候。
我就会想说
那我要不要试音一下。
虽然这个老师可能有问题。
但不要试音
因为一试音你会发现更多的问题。
当然也有这种试音了还不错的。
就是聊天
到最后我会发现
真的是我把老师的这种信息都拔光了。
他的感情经历
菲律宾国家的政策。
然后他们家有几个小孩。
然后大得做什么？
小得做什么我都拔完了。
基本上每天都是聊这些内容。
然后我觉得多了以后就没什么营养。
而且因为其实学校还是东亚学生多。
我觉得东亚人
很多时候就是会有一种过度共情。
因为我甚至遇到一个韩国同学。
他会担心说
我换课会不会影响老师的薪资。
然后也有中国的同学。
他只待两周
但是他依旧会觉得。
换完课后遇到旧的老师。
会很尴尬
然后我就说
我们过来这边是交那么多钱。
是过来当甲方的
我们就是不应该去试应老师。
就是应该去主动的。
去让老师试应我们。
去换更好的 质量更高的。
原来是换课
我还换过两个老师。
后来我跟我一个聊得比较好的老师说。
在我们这边是会影响老师的。
如果这个学生换的话。
他可能因为有些学生会写一些理由。
可能是老师的原因什么的。
然后这个老师
就会被扣掉那个三千块的奖金。
他不是零想工资
但他们有一个奖金。
三千币所还是多少。
那大概就几百块人民币吧？
大概就是这一个月的。
就是如果没有一个学生换。
他就会拿到这笔钱。
如果学生换的话
他可能就没有这笔钱。
那你们学校这个制度。
还也不中说是好还是不好。
我后来就比较慎重了。
我是任务客人才会换的。
但其实说实话
你来这里一两个月。
你如果把时间拿来忍一忍。
确实也挺浪费时间的。
有些老师真的很垃圾。
我都想投诉了
但因为我本着人道主义精神。
因为我想到会影响他们工资。
因为他们工资好低。
一个人有人民币就一两千。
然后家里有很多口人。
然后就会让我觉得算了。
就做善事了
就是不想去真的投诉他。
也有很水的
我这边也有水的老师。
就可能滑手机这种也有。
但是就是只碰到过一个吧？
其他还好
你们学校是几个学生。
什么叫几个学生
就是整个学生的规模。
我没数过
我也不太知道
我觉得
就如果我不是上亚式。
我是ESL课
我发现有时候就是。
很多人都上到最后。
就是小组课都变成一对一了。
就有段时间就是在淡季的时候。
就是可能全天后的一对一的课。
其实还是划算的
如果好好上的话
但是有些老师可能。
上日上下午的老师。
他就不按教材走了。
可能就跟我聊天了。
我口语确实还是提升挺大的。
其他地方我确实没有感受到。
很大的进步
我之前还听你说
你有个老师是哭了吗？
那个是是啥事
老师我昨天跟一个。
就是我现在在墨宝这边。
就是前睡嘛？
然后遇见一个台湾小姑娘。
她是前睡长
但她之前也是来与演学。
上了一个月
她说她跟老师聊天。
就是用英语每天聊。
然后那个老师上课。
聊着聊着就哭出来了。
她说她小的时候很穷。
为了读书多么辛苦。
然后现在这些学生。
就她那个学校
很多人就是很有钱嘛？
来到这里把妈送她过来。
然后她还跳课
学费这么这么贵
他们还跳课不愿意上课。
然后这个老师说着说着就哭了。
天呐原来是因为这个原因。
对她看来有一种
合不实肉米的感觉。
估计她就是哭这个。
也有也很难过
因为其实人生也没有什么？
很多人会觉得就是。
你不珍惜当下的学习机会。
的确
那我觉得她这哭的。
还蛮让人就是
有种反思和身形
就让我们知道
我们能有这个条件。
去选择在菲律宾有学。
已经是很幸福
很自由的一件事情。
但我现在真的觉得上进。
就是这是个大轨律的事件。
我觉得上进
它不分是不是在学校。
我觉得学习
终身学习是很重要的。
但是对于很多学生而言。
我也看到了
我刚来的时候
我有一个室友
他是越南人
他就每天躺床睡觉不想去。
我后来问他
为什么你这么贵的学费。
每个月一万多
对越南的家庭来说。
其实是很高的
我说为什么你不去上课。
他说他刚来的时候。
其实还挺用功的
上那个ESL课
转到亚斯课非常痛苦。
他觉得自己跟不上。
他很挫摆
然后他每天就越来越懒。
越来越不想去上课。
他报了五个月的
六个月的亚斯巴
五六个月的英语
因为他要去美国
希望以后去美国
但问题是
我会发现这种形式。
其实很适合
可能适合归讯官了的。
东亚人就是亚洲人。
就大家都会被这样的。
一个教学模式觉得很适应。
就比方说我选的时候。
我也觉得奥斯巴达。
肯定能让我学到更多。
但是真的符合人性吗？
我在想
就是真的所有人
都适应这样的教学方式吗？
我觉得真的很难
因为其实学生的
平均年龄的范围还是蛮广的。
然后也很多是那种。
家人把孩子送过来。
家人希望孩子去留学。
不像我们是我们自主的选择说。
我希望能够提升英语能力。
或者怎么样
所以他们本身的原动力。
就不是很足
再加上学校的规章制度。
所以很容易就是会丧失。
而且我觉得
像你的话
就一个月可能还好一点。
就是可能还有很多的新鲜感。
我可以探索一下
我到我后面检查了一个月。
我就感觉很痛苦
我就觉得这日子又变长了。
然后像他们种
要在这里读五六个月。
然后一两年的
我的天
这日子怎么过啊？
从早到晚
然后又是我们学校。
这种环境也不好的地方。
我觉得就像关在龙子里的。
狮子一样崩溃掉啊？
对
我是一般大家听到。
有一些学了六个月。
一年
大家会不约儿童的发出惊叹。
就是惊叹说这个人。
人耐力怎么可以这么强。
就这里的
我觉得教学方式
蛮适合这种雅词冲刺的。
就是你要达到几分。
然后你想要再进一两分。
你想要个全天后的学习环境。
我觉得还是可以
就像我们就考前
临时爆火脚那种感觉。
可是就是你如果真的长期想要。
在这里学
然后如果你记住不好。
老师又全都是英文的。
然后你每天从早到晚。
就是你听不懂
你也得待在那里听。
然后你听不懂
你今天的课辣了
明天又辣了
然后
你就一两年的日子怎么过呀？
所以我是会觉得这种。
就是只适合短期的游学。
我也有这种感受
对 为什么你要去学这个雅词班呢？
因为我自己是有在申请。
那个澳中的打工签证嘛？
就是我们讲的WHV。
然后它的要求是
你在被抽中之后的一个月。
要递交相关的英语成绩。
可以选雅词或者PTE。
就虽然大家攻略都会说PTE比较好。
但我会觉得雅词可能是一个。
更加被世界范围广泛认可的。
通用的能力证书
我之后也会想要有打算说。
比如说出国去工作啊？
生活一阵子
就全衡之后
我还是觉得可能去选择。
被考雅词
但我其实自己英语底子不是很差。
因为我从小就挺喜欢英语的。
学起来也不是很费劲。
澳洲的WHV的话。
它其实只要求5.5分数。
我自己入学测试后。
发现自己的水平
大概就是在可能5.5。
6.0之间
这是我被考前的一个水平。
之间波动
所以其实生前证已经够用了。
但是毕竟雅词
不是一个很便宜的考试嘛？
就想说努力被考一下。
可以考更高一点
你还是想要给自己更多的提升。
和机会可能性嘛？
我觉得你是一个
反对自己有高要求的人。
对
然后也的确还有一个原因就是。
我从可能2023年开始自由职业。
把整个澡工作的格局打开。
包括说出国旅居之后。
就会深深的感受到语言。
尤其是英语是非常重要的一个。
桥梁和工具
可以意味着更多的人生和职业的可能。
就举个例子
比如说我现在是国内一个。
旅行社的常行领队。
我们同时有国外的泄露。
但你想要变成国外领队。
肯定是会对你英语能力。
有一定的要求的
再比如我去可能求职的时候。
会发现
大部分的远程工作。
都是有外企提供
可能有时候甚至是一种。
全英的一个工作环境。
还有就是我们其实。
一开始也讲到了
我们俩都是那种比较一的。
喜欢在旅行中
就跟来自世界各地的朋友聊天。
去聆听他们的观点。
然后我觉得
这种是一种很好的。
打开自己和拥抱这个世界的一种方式。
那英语其实就是
交流中的一个最大公约数了。
其实我为什么要问你这个问题呢？
我觉得我现在听下来。
就是感觉你给了很多的理由。
我为什么问你这个问题。
其实没有这么正向的原因是什么？
因为我后面只剩不到一个月的时间。
我换到了亚斯
但是我原来是ESL。
我原来刚去之前
我觉得我是挺想考试的。
我就觉得要么我直接去学亚斯。
他们说我可能会跟不上。
对吧？
那所以我是先学了一个。
生活英语的试验
但其实我上生活英语的课。
就像你说的
我太久没学习了
也对我来说
课程量已经很大了。
一天七节课
可是换到亚斯之后。
一天九节课加三节自习。
就是十二节课
我发现所有在亚斯班上课的人。
都是没有销量的
大家都很努力的为了考试。
有一个目标的这种感觉。
然后我换过去之后。
我就知道为什么大家没有销量了。
因为还是蛮有压力的。
就是因为很多人
希望有一个好成绩的话。
那他就会需要努力吗？
是的
我们这边也有
是一些比如亚斯
他可能报了两个月。
或者三个月的一个时间。
然后他其中
过程中有一次
亚斯考试已经达到目标分数了。
但他之后会马上换掉。
不上亚斯课
会换成ESL
就相对轻松
就对他们来说是一种休闲。
不懂
因为太痛苦了
因为亚斯可能都是技巧。
其实我为什么换亚斯。
我真的就是想体验一下。
什么是亚斯
因为英语这个东西对我来说。
就是很陌生
就是很难学的一个东西。
我基础比较差
然后我觉得我这一两年。
我每次出去的时候。
我看到别人英语
好中会很羡慕
我觉得那你英语好。
你有很多的选择
可是我的英语没有这么好。
我整天都会有这样的。
一种状态
但是现在我确实觉得。
交流起来进步很多。
基本上我现在在这个清理。
我觉得他们说话
我都能听懂
我也能回复
我觉得挺好的
对啊？
因为我自己有跟你用英语交流过吗？
我是觉得你的口语。
真的就完全没有什么问题。
我就一直觉得说
你可能没有太必要学亚斯。
因为亚斯其实是完全。
只看硬式技巧
不说人话的一个考试。
它就是为了选拔
所以我觉得如果你的目标。
就是去表达和交流的话。
就没有比较给自己找最受。
表达交流是基础吗？
但是我为什么想学亚斯。
就是我会发现我在阅读上。
会有障碍
虽然我能够用口语交流了。
然后就我看一个英文的东西。
我会直接翻译
我连喵都不想喵它。
这是首先是第一点。
第二点就是我会觉得。
如果我想要学一个什么东西。
就比如说我去学瑜伽。
然后我可能还会想要去学一些。
进修一下我的花花或者别的专业。
那其实对英语还是很有要求的。
那我就觉得如果我能够提升更多。
我还是很希望我可以更加好的。
然后去了亚斯之后。
我发现我把一个青桐水平的。
拿去参加了个王子的测试。
每天就真的很崩溃 你懂吗？
我懂
因为亚斯的阅读都是偏学术型的。
它会故意用一些可能。
平常你不会的单词。
然后去考你懂不懂的同意替换之类的。
你们没有商务英语吗？
也有了
但是那个时候其实我就是想了解一下。
什么是亚斯
虽然说因为时间也不多。
因为商务英语
其实它讲很多商业的东西。
这是第一点
我们还有那个就是自信力表达的。
那个东西也很适合我。
就是你整天在修一些东西。
但那个课程是我们学校的。
NPMC吧？
是我们学校的一个特色。
就是演讲类的
但是问题是
我后面觉得就是
他们花了很多时间。
在做PPT和拍费Log。
然后跟大家Share上面。
我会觉得倒是很适合我。
只是这亚斯就是说。
如果我不去这一次在这里学的话。
我应该这辈子都不会。
靠我自己的努力去学这个东西。
因为真的很折磨
所以我就想说
行吧我就花钱找最手吧？
但说实话我验证了。
这真的是花钱找最手。
所以你验证完后
你决定这辈子就不考了。
对吧？
就是验证的结果
也没有
我觉得如果我能够好好学的话。
我还是希望能够
把这个成绩提上来的。
但是我知道它非常不容易。
所以我也接受
就是我考不好
我接受
我也不会觉得自己很挫败。
很痛苦
我只是会觉得
OK啊？
如果有一天我能
考这个
把这个成绩考好
我应该会很骄傲吧？
因为而且就是
没必要就是
我英语神经艺差
我又不是第一天知道。
那我现在已经比去年好很多了。
我已经可以交流了。
我为什么一定要要求自己是我。
我短期内就达到几分。
那我那些努力了
十几年的人怎么活呀？
是的
就是能在学校
有个概念这个考试是个什么？
对
因为我们也是每个老师。
第一节课都会问你。
为什么要考雅思
我觉得我的回答差不多。
如果我来这边
先大概看看这个
考试是什么东西
然后我其实
我可以其他的回国再自学。
你是可以自学的
我的话有难度
可能得你们这种人在我旁边吧？
我需要一个环境
我们可以搞个学习小组团。
组团可以
这真的是可以
到时候看看有没有什么机会。
是啊？
因为我们一开始
我们家微信说
我就把我对雅思
那个哥哥科目的研究的资料。
扔给你
对
我前期已经做过一些调研。
我们现在在这话有说回来。
就是
其实菲律宾这个
就学英语
我得到的消息
我后面发现
其实是17年就有人告诉我了。
因为我也是很早就知道了。
但为什么我一直割遣了这么久。
其实就会涉及到一个问题。
就是菲律宾安不安全。
首先第一
他签证很难办嘛？
第二就是会很多人会跟我说。
菲律宾很危险
我觉得我本来
新年年初就要来
然后我跟朋友说了。
他们就会天天转发给我什么？
菲律宾枪击案
绑架私票案
导致我就犹豫了老半天。
虽然我已经出过国。
我也知道国外可能不是说的这样。
只是有个别概率事件。
但是真的会让你犹豫很久。
你是怎么觉得的
我跟你今天一模一样。
就是对菲律宾这个国家。
模模糊糊的印象
就是两个大字很危险。
然后包括是国内的很多。
新闻啊？
或者身边人的一个认知啊？
基本上都是一样的。
然后我当时在数字有名社区。
大家知道以后
也有好几个就一直在欠我。
说三思
而且甚至是我买了票。
老实他们还会就是。
很不赞同的感受
对就大家好像整个普遍的认知。
都会觉得东南亚
尤其菲律宾
就是那种穷山恶水出雕民。
充满了各种安全威胁。
然后而且我来了之后。
才知道他们持乡还是合法的。
这个我来之间甚至都不知道。
对所以我这个问题。
我来到菲律宾之后。
我也问了很多人
那包括了我们学校在这边。
已经工作生活快一年的。
中国经理
那还有长时间在菲律宾。
住流的一个中国的优学中介。
包括说我们一起去博河岛。
学的那个中文清水教练。
还有说菲律宾本地的一些老师。
那结合我自己的实际感受。
我会觉得真的比来之前。
就是国内渲染的
和我自己想象中的。
要安全很多
而且没有感受到
任何所谓的排华
或者是一些不友好的。
一些歧视的态度
反而给我这边印象最深的。
就是这种很纯朴和松弛的民风。
然后会觉得他们很快乐。
而且他们那种快乐。
真的就是那种
随时给你放个音乐。
就可以扭起来
给你跳个舞的那种。
是啊？
但是就是说回来
这个安全肯定不是那种。
所谓的绝对安全的。
还是会有比如说飞车抢劫。
和偷钱的存在
就我有一个同学
他就是去可能去城市逛了一圈。
手机钱包都没了
这种可能性肯定比国内要高很多。
然后而且唯一听到一个被抢劫的案子。
就是一个学生可能。
凌晨单独行走的时候发生的。
但是我想说这种情况。
你不论放在哪个城市。
你放在中国
你凌晨四点在街头。
但是那种也很危险。
所以总的来说是没有这么吓人。
但是肯定是要基于。
你本身有一定的那种。
风险预判意识
不要把自己置于那种。
危险系数很高的环境中。
这个是第一点
还有一个就是
确实这个国家它是持枪合法的。
所以我站在门口
我有一天我要给保安教我的证件。
我保安一拉开抽屉。
就放着一把枪
我当时就
好吧就有一种震惊感。
在这里感觉好像人。
也不能说人手一把。
但接上这种警察的。
非证那种剧场的枪。
然后就还蛮神奇的一种体验感。
然后我去一些大商超。
其实说到安全就是那种大型商场。
因为他这里我觉得出问题比较大的。
也就是因为贫富差距大。
可能有一些渲染
有些人就会
可能会有一些行凶的状态。
然后大商超的时候。
就里面有钱人会比较多。
他就会让你开包检查。
所有的包都开包检查。
他们就在检查枪
原来是检查枪
但是他们又没有那种X光机。
就是拿着跟棍子撩来撩去。
我想说也没有
在查得很彻底
我真的想要藏也蛮好藏的。
但是其实我觉得坏人的话。
他没有那么镇定的。
一般就是你说你给我打开什么的。
那可能那个人的反应就不一样了吧？
我觉得大部分人
像我们这种早早拉开袋子给你看。
就打一个心理震慑。
可能就是有一点点作用吧？
做到这个我觉得我们这一次的学习。
也是相对来说比较深入的。
而且我个人
因为我已经游了一年多了。
我会觉得这比单纯的旅游。
会更加的有一层不同的文化视角。
对 因为就是你长时间的。
在学校里待着
其实你跟本地人接触最多。
就是比如我们的老师。
那我上课我也很喜欢跟老师去闲聊。
就聊他们的文化环境。
然后他们自己觉得一些差异点。
包括说他们家庭的一些背景。
就还蛮有意思的
就可以深入接触到一个个。
很具体的一个个体。
我也这么觉得
而且我真的是觉得这边。
感觉是整个亚洲跳往欧洲的一个跳板。
像什么韩国 日本。
还有我第一次见到了蒙古里尔人。
外蒙古
对 我也是
我第一次听到他们自我介绍的时候。
我说蒙古里尔是哪里玩偷偷的。
就是翻译软件查一下。
欧别人是蒙古国
那我还是马上就反映过来。
因为可能我从来
因为我们不是也有个蒙古吗？
我从来就觉得这没有这个国家一样的。
就是在我的感受里面。
对 因为国内也没有听过关于蒙古的新闻。
或者是别的一些很少 非常少。
当一个我的蒙古的英特尔。
就是也是一个类似于经理的角色。
他站在我面前的时候。
我才真正迟迟的有了一个。
这是一个国家的这种体感。
不然我觉得这个在我们的文化和认知里面。
它就像个盲区
我会觉得他们很落后。
因为一直没有听过他们的关于他们的新闻。
我就觉得他们可能还蛮蛮荒的。
发展成都不是很高的国家。
那我觉得应该也是我们接触到的蒙古的同学。
应该也是他们国内相对比较可能中产阶级以上。
才会过来
所以我觉得可能也没有办法代表。
就像我们的经理
我们学校这次我来。
我发现很多越南人。
以前三年前 你往三五年前看。
越南人没有那么多。
就是因为毕竟我觉得。
来飞冰学英语还是挺贵的。
就是我的那个经理说。
这里所有的越南人家里都很有钱。
在越南应该是非常有钱的人。
就家里有什么巨大庄园啊？
一年可能就是我那个。
我说每天躺在床上的同事。
一年可能就是什么？
多数时候Millen。
Billen就是这样算的。
可以怎么认为
就是我觉得你是真的要认知。
还要才领达到一定程度。
你才有这种出国的机会了。
或者说出国学习的机会。
你出国打工可能好一点。
就像马来西亚很多人。
他去新加坡打工就很容易。
甚至都不太需要学历的。
还有就是我会觉得。
我之前不是说
我说菲律宾人的工资其实很低吗？
就觉得他们才一两千工资。
但不知道为什么？
我感觉他们好像很开心。
就那种随处可唱
随处可跳舞的那种感觉。
对 我自己对这一点。
也是感受蛮深刻的。
我觉得他们会有一种。
东亚人梦寐以求的。
一种松弛和幽默感。
就比如我们客间休息。
也就五分钟
那老师们可能就会聚集在走廊。
然后开聊天
然后经常会性之所致的时候。
就开始隐含高歌
甚至可能好几个老师一起合唱。
就随时随地
变成歌舞青春模式的那种感觉。
一出了门就开始跳舞。
对吧 对 真的夸张。
甚至在厕所排队的时候。
也是想唱就唱要唱的。
想晾 蛮感染人的。
有时候特别感觉也好像。
就是有一种过于松弛。
他们好像不太愿意。
就是很折磨自己的那种感觉。
就是没有那么？
中国人那么上进那么卷吧？
对 因为这个我也跟。
我的老师聊过嘛？
他说大部分菲律宾人。
都不是那种特别精进和勤奋。
甚至可以
他自己的原话
可以称之为懒散或者懒惰。
比如说像菲律宾他就很喜欢。
大家庭嘛？
所以一个家庭可能会有五六个孩子。
但是他们可以一大家子这么多人。
只靠一个人去工作赚钱。
其他人就可以心安理得的在家。
就是混吃混喝 对。
就对他们来说
可能感觉有满足自己生存。
基本需要的钱就够了。
比如在公司让他升职加薪。
但是让他可能承担。
更多的责任花更多的时间。
一般都是会拒绝的。
但他们又对家庭
就是他们没有很多自我的那个部分。
他们把家庭放在一个很高的位置。
就家庭快乐
他们就快乐很多时候是这样。
就很注重你家庭为单位的。
这样子的构建的一种生活。
我后来看到一个说法是什么？
第一个是天主教国家。
他可能比较重视这些东西。
我不知道
第二个是什么？
因为菲律宾不是有很多个岛嘛？
然后他们一地震又多。
洪灾又多
然后刮台风又多
就站在很多的国家就是这种。
所以他们就不努力的。
不上进了反正也没什么用。
然后他们就把这精神放在这种。
就是这种爱和关系的维护上。
那的确地理和自然也是会。
很深深地影响一个民族的那种。
底层的性格
像你刚刚说到那个多生孩子这一点。
我觉得
就是我在街上看到很多的。
HOME LACE。
就是因为我在市区嘛？
那个学校
我们这个学校虽然很破。
但它在市中心
非常非常中心的位置。
然后一出门
市中心
就街上就有很多这种光着绑子的。
然后一晒得油黑油黑的。
然后身上看起来很脏。
头发很乱的这种
这种流浪汉
流浪儿就剧毒
我们学校是在郊区。
但是反而我一个流浪汉都没看到。
因为我后来问我的老师为什么？
他说其实他们大部分都不是。
宿物这个城市里的人。
他们都是很偏远的地方。
会过来的
就流浪的过来
然后这里起套啊？
就可以吃饭了
所以可能这就是为什么？
可能反而繁华的
他觉得他们可能起套的可能性。
会更大
所以就是往那边去巨龙。
我发现菲律宾他平复。
他觉得真的非常的大。
因为这个流浪汉还蛮多的。
然后那些老师说
我问他们原因是什么？
他说就是越穷越深。
越深越穷
然后他们不知道
但他们就孩子就生下来生下来。
然后他们印象很为深刻的。
就是我们这个异海。
异海政策
他们觉得还挺好的。
就比较包变不一
但他们说
玩丘军
Policy大概就异海政策吧？
很难
因为天主教不是不能脱胎吗？
对
就是他们是不可以脱胎的。
感觉避孕一些避孕的措施。
对他来说成本其实还蛮高的。
第一这个成本很高。
第二是我感觉
他们在教育普及上。
也没有这个意识
比较少
就是很多人对这方面他是没有教育。
而且他会比较尊崇于这种历史发展。
就是尊崇于家庭单位。
那你就会像中国的话。
我觉得有很多传下的这种习俗。
就像我爷爷什么重男轻女。
怎么传宗接代的习俗。
那我不知道他们有没有。
但是我感觉肯定会。
就顺着就下来了
然后刚刚讲到天主教。
因为我们其实都知道。
天主教他其实是不支持同性恋的。
但我会发现就是一个很矛盾。
但是很冲突的一个点就是。
他们整个社会
会氛围反而是对同性恋。
或者是LGBTQ群体特别特别的包容。
就我们学校可以看到。
非常多Ladyboy的老师。
包括Gate的老师。
他们就非常的优雅。
丛容自信大方
我觉得他这种自信是非常底层的。
是来自于他们被自己的社会。
自己的家庭一个深深的认可和接受。
就只要他们的存在。
就是跟顺子男顺子女一样。
被当作是一个非常合理的事情。
就甚至不用讲到去背认可。
就存在即合理
对他们真的接上随书可见各种职业。
而且这种职业还更加的有便利度。
比如说我们的老师。
服务业都更愿意用Ladyboy。
就是他更愿意就
就用他上
你去外面你看店餐的餐厅里就很多。
你随处可见
就哪儿哪儿都有Ladyboy。
你转身
我在超市里准备买个东西。
然后我咨询一下
然后五大三厨
而且他们都很五大三厨。
还有就是感觉胡子都刮不干净的Ladyboy。
然后穿这个死瓦高跟鞋。
就很多你知道吗？
我觉得在我们原来的印象里。
就觉得泰国
它是比较很知识同心恋。
然后有这种第三性别的国家。
然后菲律宾是完全没有这个概念的。
来了以后因为我在泰国也蛮久。
我甚至觉得他
有时候我就觉得他比泰国还要自然的感觉。
是的 感觉那个浓度还要更高。
这个接受度就感觉就是。
哎 这就是他们的人种。
就是他们生下来就这样。
然后我还问过我的阅读老师嘛？
就是他的那个兴趣。
就是一个Gate的老师。
然后非常有趣 非常可爱。
然后他说他从他自己五岁的时候。
就已经发现自己喜欢穿女装。
然后喜欢男生
他当时就已经跟他家人公开出柜了。
然后就很震惊
我说那你的家人
不会就是对你有什么负面评价。
或者不接受吗？
他说完全没有啊？
就在菲律宾基本上。
不论你是什么样的。
你都会被家人无条件的爱和接受。
就无关护你的兴趣项。
然后当我跟他分享的时候。
比如说我可能在国内啊？
或者是整个东亚的街上。
都不太会有就LGPDQ群体。
去做一些比较亲密的举动。
或者约会的时候
他就觉得还挺震惊的。
对啊 我有一个Lady Boy的老师。
他也是这么跟我说的。
他说 我就问他小的时候。
他多少时候发现
然后他的父母有什么反应。
真的就是完全都是支持他的。
而且很爱他的
他说他在感受到
那个家庭对他的包容度很高。
我觉得这个可能是他们松弛的。
一个很大的原因
就是只要你开心都可以。
对 就是全人的接纳。
你想做什么都可以。
然后你想成为谁
你是什么样的
就都可以
我发现确实是这样。
整个社会这块包容度很高。
不过我又有担心
我感觉好像这个Lady Boy。
或者是Gay代人数比例。
在菲律宾还挺高的。
那他们这些女性可能。
真的只能找外国人结婚比较多。
你是不是看到了什么？
就是确实我们前一阵子去那个。
外面去游泳吗？
去拉布拉布游泳
然后我们有的时候发现一个。
英国的老百男在那边。
然后就发现一个女的。
我们聊天吧？
就跟她聊 聊得挺开心的。
我发现英语好了以后都听得懂。
我现在很开心
然后我就发现
这个女生她可能是几十年前。
这个老百男来菲律宾游玩的时候。
请的地赔
也就是租期服务
可能就是
然后可能就变成真的妻子了。
就是直接带回英国了。
哇塞 我的天哪
阶级乐生吧 这是。
我也觉得
感觉就是整个都不一样了。
是的 经常可以看到很多。
就是老百男玩着
年轻的菲律宾女生走在街上。
我记得这边的话
性交易也是合法的 对吧？
这个太过一样了
你来到这边
也算是待了一个多月。
你有没有什么？
特别印象深刻的同学。
在这种语言学校里。
还有蛮多的
我就分享一个
就是我
可能算是最深刻的。
是我一个口语小班课的同班同学。
他是一个阿拉伯人。
他是那个沙特阿拉伯的。
他在他们原来的国家。
是做安全工程师的。
也是刚辞职
想要去提升自己的英语能力。
那后来听别人说
他们家其实很有钱。
就有自然飞机的那种。
就是加深了一下
阿拉伯人都很有钱的。
可不可以印象
笑死
然后就是在课上跟他聊天的时候。
我就会觉得他虽然有口音。
但是他整体的那种。
表达的自信度和流畅度。
我觉得在学校里面。
可能算得上是排得上前二十的。
我就很好奇说
你来这里多久了
就他说他才来这里一个月不到。
而且他刚来的时候。
甚至只会一些
非常简单的英语单词。
我当时就蛮震惊的。
就是他进步真的很快。
然后我就还发现他另一点。
就是他是一个非常交界花。
就走在路上就一直。
就有人给他打招呼。
认识学校里非常多的人。
我就好奇说
你平时都怎么学习。
或者说怎么社交了。
他说我在路上随便看到一个人。
我就会搭上上去打话说。
How are you? Where are you from?。
然后如果对方可能比较冷漠。
他也不会觉得很受伤。
他就可能就回忆
就是We should have a good day。
然后就结束对话
所以他其实是通过这样子的。
大量的就是主动的去社交打话。
然后练习
让他自己的口语和他的朋友数量。
都就是指数级的增长。
那我觉得这个是一个非常好的一个点。
就是真的社交很重要。
我现在清理其实我发现。
真的年轻的探索育真的是更重要了。
其实不比语言更重要。
我有时候我会觉得很多的那种羞耻感。
是我们自己给自己夹的。
我现在倒也不是羞耻感。
只是我可能就是没有那么有劲的。
去聊天了
就有点累
没有这个社交动力。
但是你讲那个社交羞耻感。
我就不论是中国人。
就放在整个东亚来讲。
大家好像都会很害怕去表达。
或者会害怕被拒绝。
就对我们来说好像是一件很难的事情。
但是对于好像阿拉伯人来讲。
就完全不是一个问题。
他理解不了
因为我们在课上也讨论了这个事情。
当时有个话题就是你的理想班旅。
我有同学就提到了一个。
表达自己表达爱的能力。
然后我就问他说
你们国家会去跟父母说I love you吗？
我其他同学都是来自。
要把日本韩国台湾。
大家就起刷刷的摇头。
就录出那种很恐惧的表情说。
我从来没有做过
我也做不出来
然后只有一个阿拉伯同学就很震惊说。
我每天都说
这就是什么很难的事吗？
他当下就拿出了手机。
要给他妈发了一个语音。
知道妈妈I love you。
然后他妈秒回
就是说我也爱你之类的。
然后就让我们还是觉得。
这样子的一种差异性还是蛮大的。
我也确实有这种感受。
反正我现在就是有。
我觉得
对他可能在这种社交文化上。
还是有很强
和情感文化上有很强的不同。
包括我之前那个朋友。
他其实也就跟中东的小哥哥约会过。
他说他们整直就是。
甚至有点过度表达。
就每天都在疯狂地夸你。
然后发自内心地夸你。
觉得你什么都好
有一道甜言蜜语
对他们来说就是信守年来。
会不会就是太正常了。
发现有一种很奇怪的感觉。
不配得感
就是中亚人和中东人。
中亚人中东人混合一下。
找个平衡点我觉得挺好的。
但是的确他跟他的聊天。
对我来说起发蛮大的。
就是在他身上看到了一种。
完全没有表达持感。
没有阻力的一种流动感觉。
然后我当天我就给自己下了个KPI。
因为我也想去社交。
但是也会像你讲说。
会害怕会被拒绝
给自己想象很多一种困难。
或者说一种社交的困境。
然后说我今天必须要主动。
跟两个同学打话
然后我就挑了一个。
看起来好像很不好惹。
连很臭的坐在泳池边。
用iPad画画的一个男生。
然后后来其实你真正聊了以后。
其实发现大家真的都很nice。
很开放很包容
你就会慢慢地意识到。
很多困难很想象是你自己给自己的。
其实卖出内部真的没有那么难。
我很难过
我现在在孟宝住的那个青绿。
我的天
我发现都不用去外面了。
比电视剧要那些帅哥还好看。
那个身材比例
那个肌肉
那个就是真的都很好看。
而且感觉全部都是。
你看到的那种国外明星级别的。
我现在这个青绿里面。
你知道吗？
我发现不要去住什么中国人店了。
真的就是这些青绿里面。
而且很舒服
躺着外国人静音的特别好。
然后这个男生真的是。
是那种九头身比例的。
而且我还不看到不止他一个。
你知道吗？
前几天
周末的时候更多
就这两天比较淡
然后这个男生就一直住着。
因为我也一直住着。
我今天早上看了他的时候。
其实我特别想跟他聊个天。
因为他太帅了
我实在是不好意思。
我很害羞
我不敢开口
因为他也是帅了
就是真的
像这种帅到这种级别的你就觉得。
而且挺多的
我就不敢聊天
然后昨天晚上我就出去那个。
三分野来本去那个便利店。
买东西的时候
排队的时候有一个人。
凶天抱着一只小狗。
那小狗长得好可爱。
嘴巴上一圈是烟灰色。
然后我就开始聊天。
我就跟他说
哎 你哪里的
然后他跟我说是什么？
应该也是中东的什么？
什么什么斯坦的一个国家。
没听清
然后他很乐意还跟我聊中文。
哎 我现在很后悔。
没有加他的联系方式。
我觉得不然的话
我可以教他中文
然后他跟我练英语也挺好的。
哎呦 我现在有点小难过。
因为就是只是在便店。
然后人有很多
我就不太好意思
我现在就觉得
不好意思这个东西就应该去掉。
拿他干嘛用
能换 能换什么？
真的是
真的是勇敢主动人才会。
真的先想说事件
先因为有故事
哦 我现在很愚闻。
我觉得就应该不要。
啊 讨厌死了
还有就是
啊 才那么一两天。
我要努力一下
哎 我好难突破这个障。
我看到帅的我就不行。
就聊不了天
我就 就是嘴巴就不动了。
好难过
给自己下一个社交挑战。
真的 我真是跟自己定KPI。
我还故意说
我今天要搭讪学校里好看的。
就是一个好看的女生。
和一个好看的男生。
就是为了断绝自己这种。
就像你说的
你遇到帅的
就会更加大的心理阻力。
其实没有什么？
就是觉得大家会
觉得好看的人
会拥有更多的社会资源。
就天然会觉得
跟他们有一种
阶级差 或者怎么样的。
所以我们心里是把自己。
跟他们放在了一种。
所谓的不平等的位置。
才会觉得我们就跟她聊天。
好像是一种在向上社交。
所以自然这种
所谓的向上
就会有更大的阻力感。
这个词本身就有很多阻力感。
我觉得就是有一种趣味。
没有趣味
就是你对她有一种滤镜。
我觉得就是这个滤镜。
造成了这种自己
好像给自己放低了的。
就是感觉明星说话的感觉。
我自己分析了
这些心理动静
就会觉得好像
比如说好看的人
她天生会有更
更强的所谓的优越感。
所以会觉得
对会觉得好像天然他们的性格。
就会比可能
没有那么好的外在的人。
会更加难以接触
你会觉得去跟她聊天。
会更多的
会收到一些冷漠的回应。
这是你的一个心理预设。
对 我自己分析
我自己会讲
那我之前在另一个。
妈妈岛情侣的时候。
我碰见有两个
有个男生给我的
是这种感受
也很帅也很帅
我之前去妈妈岛潜水。
我这个女生也好好看。
这个身材比例
就是特别特别好看。
然后那个男生也是。
我就觉得我在
我在这里很养眼
就是你每天感觉就是那种。
大片
就每个都很好看的那种。
就你去这种旅游名圣地。
就欧美人很多的地方。
就会很极大程度的。
碰见这种人
然后特别我去住情侣。
我觉得情侣里面
就已经很多了解
很帅
很好看
真的
然后就你都不用去外面找。
你可以看得到很多。
真的我养眼
蓝天美景 帅哥美景。
然后我发现他们挺愿意住情侣的。
可能是想要借交各种不同的朋友。
但我好像在情侣
我也很少去交朋友。
而且我觉得这个是我的问题。
不是他们的问题
那我头疼
我看看今天我能不能打开一点。
不知道怎么聊
突然就一个人的时候还好。
然后突然他们坐在那边。
一堆人打牌
但其实我知道他们都不认识。
只住到这里就开始玩了。
然后我就在想
我又不会玩游戏
假装会不会很奇怪。
那就试一试
我突然变成了爱人。
对
那就试一试
反正我自己时间下来。
反正自己的预设全都是假的。
就是大家都很nice 很友好。
甚至比如说我刚刚说的。
看起来脸很臭的那个男生。
他甚至很欣喜
有人跟他打话
因为他刚来这个学校。
没多久他英文超级赖。
他不敢跟别人主动社交。
冲
那行
我今天给自定的KPR。
就是加入他们的战局。
我要把这个完成
其实我发现就是
我这边
就是因为日本学生比较多。
他们确实也不太会开口。
但还是要看人的
而且我在这边
其实我那个学校
中国人是很多的
我碰见很多中国人。
我原来发现很多人。
他不愿意在国外跟中国人聊天。
他就有中国人就很没意思。
说实话大概率是这样的。
但是
因为中国人你可以聊得更深入一点。
你其实会发现
出了国的国人
也各有各的故事
也蛮有意思的
举例方说
不想在国内卷的
带着孩子在各地找机会。
找什么国际学校的这种家长。
虽然他们没什么很深度的东西。
但又觉得也挺佩服的。
因为带孩子出国
蛮心类的
说实话
然后
还有就是
我碰见了一个朋友。
因为我原来
有当了两年都在国外。
我就出过没什么？
也没什么大事
然后那个朋友
他之前在丽江
当了十几年的歌手。
当很多年
然后他就会觉得
他说
他觉得都是缘分在这里见面的。
他说每一个真的来到这里的人。
他的内心都牵回白转的。
可能想了很多遍
然后我就觉得
因为他们不是那种很年轻出来的。
然后身上都各有各的故事。
还有一个之前在非洲。
我看他头像
还真的就玩过枪的那种。
还在缅甸的那种
就是战乱驱逐过几年。
是一个女生
特别帅
还去参加这种极限的。
那种蓝天救援队
极限救援
这种蛮有意思的
有意思的人的频率好像。
这个人群画像又更高了。
对
感觉他就是一个巨大的。
一个筛选器
然后把大家聚在这里的人。
总会有一些共性在。
好呀？
那我们最后再来总结一下。
你感觉这个潜画的值吗？
我觉得值也不值
值的话就是
我的确享受了
对
我们是抓紧了每一个周末。
享受了菲律宾
非常丰富的
一个海洋的旅游资源嘛？
然后也的确收获了游学。
这件事本身的体验。
然后我的音乐能力也有提升。
所以我就从这几点来讲。
我觉得还蛮值的
那你觉得呢？
我觉得
因为我原来就是
抱着提升音语来的。
如果你把
你给自己设立一个目标。
然后很单一
你没有完成他的手。
你其实是很挫败的。
那我觉得他肯定是没有说。
像我来之前觉得
来这种斯巴达学校。
他就能拯救我的英语的那种程度。
但他确实也是让我进步了。
可是当我发现
我住到这个清理之后。
我觉得
如果只是纯粹为了聊天。
我应该找一个清理住上一个月。
也进步很快
就是这种感受
但还是不一样
因为亚洲人嘛？
你知道你要打开
你要真的能聊起来。
人家有没有这个耐心跟你聊。
我觉得还是要去找学校。
老师会比较耐心的引导嘛？
那现在我能够在清理聊。
也是因为基于我进步了嘛？
我觉得也是这个很重要的。
还有一个就是
我会觉得确实口语流利了很多。
虽然我会觉得亚斯他很贵。
也对我没有什么考亚斯的作用。
但是他起码也给我了一个新的维度。
就是我觉得人生所有的经历。
还是一个成长吧？
那你说你如果只是抱着一个音语成绩。
能提升多少的这个程度。
那可能真的要说一说。
怎么样的人适合来这个菲律宇学音语了。
就比如说你成绩非常非常差。
你很讨厌音语
你来感受感受这样的教学方式。
可能让你能够适应。
或者你成绩已经很还不错了。
我5分左右你想5.5分左右。
你想考个6进一个半分一分大。
我觉得也蛮合适的。
是
我自己来这边最大的提升。
也是没有了口语羞耻。
因为来之前虽然我的可能基础。
词后语法都不是很差。
但是我会发现我自己。
甚至对着CHAT GPT都开不了口。
对
但是到了后面的时候。
其实你就完全自如的真的可以把音语。
当成自己的第二种语言去表达和沟通。
这种感觉还是蛮好的。
但你刚刚也讲了嘛？
对
如果你有很具体的提分的这个诉求的话。
那我会觉得不是特别。
这个钱花的不是特别值得。
不过主要也是
我才待了一个月时间太短了。
就你前期你不能去哪个学校。
你都会要时间去适应。
比如学校的学习强度。
它很紧凑的日程
或者找到适合自己的老师和学习方式。
那我觉得这个模合成本至少都要一到两周。
那所以实际上有成效的学习。
那可能是在我换老师之后。
也就是大概两周的时间。
所以从这个角度上来讲。
我觉得可能这个学习的投产比不是很值。
所以如果时间拉长一点的话。
我觉得才可以去比较好的去贪保。
这个入学前期固定的一个适应成本。
可能大概两个月的话。
我觉得会比较值
但是这个两个月又讲回你的自己的心理。
能不能承受这样子。
一种强度和制度
所以真的还蛮难讲的。
反正我觉得两个月。
就是如果你还有很强的意愿。
两个月够了
然后如果你不要超过三个月。
你可能最后真的会生无可怜。
基本上我觉得很想学习。
非常有目标的人
在这一次待藏过三个月以上。
也是面露彩色
对
所以我是觉得非常不适合的一类人。
是你雅思可能本身差不多在6分左右。
然后想要短时间内迅速提分。
比如说一个月
这种的话我觉得你就直接抱国内的。
比如说学位柜
我自己研究会觉得学位柜比较好。
不是什么广告
然后因为你出来后会发现。
像中国人在硬实提分这一块。
还是在世界范围内很有优势的。
因为我自己来之前就看了一些。
B站的一些UP主的免费的视频。
我觉得比可能在这边。
老师一个月交道的。
对我来说提分还更有用。
可能一个视频就够了。
我关于什么是雅思。
我根本不需要在这里学。
我现在都这么觉得。
不过也没关系吧？
我觉得人生就是一种经历吧？
而且他会帮你去更了解自己。
就比如说我们也算有个收获吧？
就考了个潜水证
真的就感受到了
比如说在菲律宾学英语。
高强度全日治学英语。
是一种什么样的体验。
这也是一种很难以被取代的一种收获。
我觉得做什么样的人生选择。
肯定都有你的理由。
相信自己也为自己所做出的决定买单。
这就是最好的
不要后悔和内耗
因为确实也没有什么用吧？
这里是强力墙外
让我们陪你一起探索人生。
更多的可能性
下期见
就像每个音笔都有真凡两面。
难遇见天气暴
说明天有雪
可悲望路里明天有月。
一个世界
生活在不同季节
这样两个人竟然遇见。
我喜欢夏天的热烈。
你热爱冬天的春节。
我穿着棉奥你穿拖鞋。
我喜欢南方的夏夜。
你偏爱北方的风月。
春夏秋冬扭转世界。
想爱的人不要失约。
人生海海我等你出现。
因为这个世界不止夏天。
不一样的人终将遇见。